Is it okay for a cancer patient to
To eat meat. I heard someone say that anyone with cancer should be vegan
You see a lot of those claims out there
Even you know by sources that you know are trying to be
Coaches of people that have cancer say that everybody should do this or everybody should do that now there are some general
You know everybody should do if you have cancers like you know, you know, even if you didn't have cancer
Everybody should be eating less sugar or everybody should be eating less grains or everybody should be
Trying to eat organic. I mean those are a given just natural
Understanding of trying to stay away from toxins try to stay away from things that raise your blood glucose levels try to stay as healthy as possible
So that is a given but when you
Classify it down like everybody who has cancer should go on a ketogenic diet. Well
That's just not correct or everybody who has cancer should go on a
Meat-free diet, which is basically the opposite of a ketogenic diet should go vegan
You hear that out there everybody with cancer should be juicing 12 glasses of juice
Vegetables use a day or everybody of cancer should go on a raw food diet
Those are I think very incorrect statements because everybody with cancer is different and
Everybody with cancer their cancer can change and different things can be feeding the cancer
So if you're in a vegan diet the dangers of a vegan diet is that you're not getting enough protein in order to make
T cells and natural killer cells that are essential for killing cancer
So often you'll see people on a vegan diet that do
well and some and very often to see people on a vegan diet when they have cancer or not that look horrible their health is suffering greatly
So to be on a specific diet because it's a fan. I think it's very
Beyond a specific diet because
You just heard you know a video on Instagram that said everybody should do this. I think it's is is foolishness and
The same thing with ketogenic diets ketogenic diet good for everybody. Well, no, it may not be
so you just want to get as specific as possible and
That's gonna be the best way as far as you're gonna treat cancer is everyone is different and you
Need a protocol that's specific to you as an individual
Not in some generality because you know
I got healed at a vegan diet that means everybody that I talked to should be on a vegan diet
That's narcissism. That's
No, honestly, you know, and you see a lot of practitioners do that
Okay, with my cancer meat did drive my cancer, so I stayed off of meat
I don't know and
You know, I think there was parts of me that suffered because I was on a more vegan diet while I was in the throes of my cancer
But there's parts of it that help because I you know got tested and
Meat wasn't driver for my my cancer, so I had to stay free from it
But then there got to a point where it wasn't anymore and I was able to go back to eat it and and it my health
Improved in other ways because of that so going on a strict diet that you're eliminating certain food groups
Remember the Bible says that God made everything to be good for man to eat
What he created it
Now of course, we as humans have distorted a lot of things
So what do we do eat? We want to eat grass-sped meat as much as organic grass-sped meat as much as possible or
Wild caught salmon as much as possible. So you do your best to try to eat things that are clean
But you don't follow fan diets. You don't listen to Instagram
Influencers you don't even listen to practitioners who are giving one
Size fits all to everybody. I just think that's wrong
You want to be very specific to you as an individual and get tested
Individually what could be driving your cancer and that's what you want to stay away from is just what's driving your cancer